we really need your help we need arrow
wanna know everything about this green
era where he lives and who he loves
took a bullet
hey youtubers its charlie another arrow
season 4 promo that offers a better look
at damian darhk-- and a couple things
going on into the season and we also got
some news on some of the characters so
big stuff first let's talk about the
footage damian darhk-- it looks like he
might be a metahuman now that's not the
case in the comic books but arrow
changes characters in subtle ways all
the time a lot of times what they'll do
if there's a character from the comics
that they want to use that isn't like
Batman or Superman or some major
character and they feel like said
character maybe wasn't done justice in
the comic that they appeared in then
they might change it a little bit make a
little bit better Merlin is the best
example that Malcolm Merlyn is a huge
character in the comics but most of the
stories that he appeared and in the
classic comics just weren't that great
so they changed it to their version and
you get the John Barrowman Malcolm
Merlyn which i think is better
Neal mcdonoughs damian darhk-- is just
gonna be another shade of that but the
interesting thing is is that is totally
possible that he could be a naturally
occurring metahuman they're trying to do
that more and more in the arrowverse but
look at his left hand here he has a
wedding ring on or it looks like a
wedding ring so he could also be doing
this with technology what this is really
saying is is that he is almost
indestructible bullets arrows your
standard fare is not gonna stop him it's
just the next step up on the villain
ladder - Vandal Savage someone who's
actually immortal if you don't remember
Rachele gold during season 3 told oliver
the damian darhk-- whenever he left the
League of Assassins took waters from the
Lazarus Pit so that's why he looked so
young but he joined the league at the
same time that Rachel Gould did so he's
actually very very old the rest of the
trailer is all about embracing darkness
now that's mostly about Thea's character
she just starts to go a little bit nuts
not like crazy nuts but like taking
crazy risks nuts taking big big risks
with her life they said that's also
gonna be the case whenever Sarah Lance
comes back the white canary she's not
gonna be quite as nuts as Thea's but
it's like if death can't stop me then
what's there to be afraid of it's like
the way Wolverine looks at the world you
know he knows he's going to instantly
regenerate so he just throws himself
into fights that much more
who cares if my body gets destroyed I'll
just grow it right back damian darhk--
also named drops green arrow now the
footage from this is just from the first
couple of episodes so we might actually
end up seeing Oliver take the name green
arrow in the first episode and look in
the background of this to look at the
cord industry
name plastered over everything so either
damian darhk-- has co-opted cord
industries or he's just stealing stuff
from him ted kord blue beetle from the
comics very good character so he
wouldn't be working with hive by choice
you guys let me know that do you think
that damian darhk-- is gonna be a
naturally occurring metahuman do you
think they're just changing his comic
book character just to make him more
threatening or do you think he's using
technology to do this and do you think
that he's stealing from cord industry is
stealing all these weapons the
organization that he works for is called
hive now we've seen it on arrow before
like they've been teasing it it's all
about the mystery of diggle's brother's
death the showrunners tease that
thematically arrow season 4 is all about
the true meaning of family like what
would you do for family what about your
adopted family versus the family you're
born with you know very common themes
there's a lot of those relationships
inside team arrow like Diggle and Oliver
adopted brothers then you have Thea
who's born to Malcolm who she totally
hates so it's like sometimes you can't
pick your family but sometimes you do
get to pick your family is blood thicker
than water that's why there's a lot of
rumors that damian darhk-- might be
Felicity's father they might be doing
the Darth Vader Princess Leia thing
which is funny just because Stephen
Amell talks about Star Wars all the time
that's just idle speculation but Jamie
dark a lot of his qualities are similar
things that you see in Felicity's
character like they're both geniuses and
what would be better than presenting
Felicity with that situation where she
has to choose between the father that
she didn't know that she had in the
family that she's chosen for herself
like the family that she's trying to
make with Oliver the friends that she's
made inside team arrow those bonds so
it's just like throwing more gasoline on
that theory that Felicity's secret
father is the big villain on arrow
I think the thing you guys are really
gonna enjoy about damian darhk-- this
season is that he is openly a villain in
broad daylight Iquitos he waltzes right
in and says yeah I'm definitely the bad
guy your city is dying I want to help
you let it die the fun thing about
cities dying is that it actually kind of
reminds me of coast city during the
reign of the Superman story line when
cyborg superman essentially obliterated
coast city from the map that was
actually the event in the comics that
led Hal Jordan to become parallax and it
set off this big zero hour arc that was
a long long time ago but we also see
Amanda Waller and Oliver in the
flashback and they might be doing the
flashbacks in coast city this year we
know a little bit more about what's
going on in present-day that we know
what's going on to the flashbacks but
I'm really
to see amanda waller back so really cool
news we also learned some new things
about some of the Flash characters most
importantly i think that wally west is
not going to be kid flash in season 1 or
right away they said it's gonna be like
roy coming on arrow and then becoming
arsenal over a certain period of time
look I think Colton Haynes was on arrow
for a whole year before they even got
close to Arsenal
that was arrow season 2 and he came on
kind of at the end of arrow season 1 so
what's probably gonna happen is is that
we'll just see Wally West for the
duration of season 2 and then maybe like
at the very end he'll start to become
kid flash we'll start to see that happen
but they did say that he would be
connected to STAR Labs during the season
he'd become part of that team at a
certain point so that remains to be seen
as to how that happens but just remember
he's not gonna be kid flash right away
when we need him and I'll do I'll do
another flash video in a couple days I
just I don't want to do one right away
but we learned a few things about some
of the characters like patty spivot the
zoom character they're changing some
things about zoom from the comics so
just stay tuned for that be sure to
subscribe to get everything
there's also a Jessica Jones Marvel
teaser now it really is like the soul of
a teaser because there's very little
footage of actual jessica jones in it so
i'm gonna post that next i've done a
couple of jessica jones videos but i'll
let you guys know about that whenever i
post that video i know some of you guys
have also been asking me about going on
screen junkies i am actually going on
their show it's like Friday the 18th I
think it's whichever Friday that is so
it'll be like in another week or two
like right before Doctor Who airs so why
you guys wait for my Jessica Jones video
you can click here for the latest flash
trailer and you can click here to learn
all about Jessica Jones thank you so
much watching everybody high five I'll
see you guys tonight